genuinely sister Nadia I want to know
why I know somebody's going to send you
this video yeah and you can take this as
me attacking you for whatever you want
to look genuinely sister I am so curious
that on your Instagram you are posting
about your book you're posting about
different other stuff I'm just
curious why would you not do one single
post just one I'm just C I'm genuinely
asking
why
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana
waala
brothers and sisters and dear friends I
was scrolling down on Instagram and I
came across this picture and at first I
didn't realize which account shared it
and then I realized before that that I
thought this was actually sister Nadia
herself who is basically guilty that she
didn't speak much about it I'll be
honest I don't know nothing about her
account I don't follow her so I thought
maybe oh she just acknowledge that she
hasn't spoken about it and she's
basically taking herself to account
little did I know that that was a
Photoshop um I thought that was done by
her and then I realized and said hold on
a second let me go go to a page is this
from her and I went to her page and I'll
be honest with you I was so so
disappointed now as Muslims we are told
to assume the best in Believers we
assume the best I want to ask some
questions I don't want to go on a little
you know mad Rampage Etc accusing that
all this kind of stuff it's an emotional
situation I am upset I am angry very
angry actually because if that was our
children if if our kids were going
through 10% of what they were going
through we would lose our mind I've had
people come to me and say you know
what's the point of boycott what's the
point of this what's the point of that
it's simple to me it's very simple if my
children if my 5year five-month-old
daughter that I pick up in my hand and
her smile brightens up my day and to see
her even be upset or just cry or my 2
and a halfy old daughter or my
six-year-old daughter to see a their
fingertip being hurt makes my heart
shiver not only that yesterday my wife
sent me a voice note of my daughter
crying for me you know where's Daddy you
know crying even that knowing that I'm
going to be coming back home I felt it
in my heart I genuinely felt it and I I
was rushing home you know and I told my
wife don't put her to bed until I come
cuz she didn't want to go to bed early
yeah she's 2 and a half three years old
yeah so that touched my heart so just
imagine for a second brothers and
sisters and sister Nadia you have kids
you have teenagers if I'm not mistaken
they are children they are babies
imagine them you carry them in your hand
and you are carrying their body parts
not their body you are carrying their
body parts a leg missing the head
smashed blown into
pieces sometimes you can't even
recognize them how can you I'm just
asking look please I don't want nobody
to go to her and give a hate message
your friends stop being pathetic it's
stop being childish I'm angry I'm upset
I just want to know why genuinely sister
Nadia I want to know why I know
somebody's going to send you this video
yeah and you can take this as me
attacking you for whatever you want to
look genuinely sister I am so curious
that on your Instagram you are posting
about your book you're posting about
different other stuff I'm just
curious why would you not do one single
post just just one I'm just C I'm
genuinely asking why it might be that
you have a family issue what but you
post about a book you post about a book
this is the am this is an am that you
have Allah subhana will hold you
accountable my dear sister I'm again the
fact that you posted about the book I'm
just I don't know what to think of it
I'm in double Minds you know I'm trying
to control myself not to be angry but
again you post the book of your book or
whatever it is for that matter but why
can you not talk about our brothers and
sisters please I would love an
explanation we would all love an
explanation the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said you
either enjoying good or forid evil or
Allah will send down a Calamity that
even if you prostrate will be rejected
from you enjoying good and forid evil is
what makes this um so great yes that the
other nations didn't uh um stopped doing
we speak against it the prophet PE said
if you see an evil action try to stop it
with your hand IB T says this is people
of authority maybe we can't do it yes if
somebody's fighting on the road we can
stop them yes if you can't do that speak
out against it every single person who
cannot even maybe speak have a speech
impairment yeah they can type they can
talk about it they can share a post yes
it is capable for everybody to do that
if you can't do that at least hit it in
your heart it's the lowest form of IM we
want to go not for the lowest one we
want to do what we can do we should talk
about it boycott make Dua do these
things so my dear sister Nadia
I want to assume the best even though
like I said you've shared the book The
Post let's put that to aside for
whatever reason it might be please tell
us why you have not spoken about this so
vocally I want to know if only and if we
assuming the best if it is because of
the heat that you're going to get shame
on you if if if it is another matter for
whatever reason it might be that is
holding you back we assume the best and
we ask Allah to allow you to overcome
that but in the meantime if there's
other things you're posting please my
dear sister we want to know why are you
not raising awareness you have if I'm
not mistaken I don't I don't know is it
5 600,000 uh followers for that matter
or I is it the millions I don't even
know let me see you have
885,000 nearly a million people watching
you my dear sister you will be held
accountable on please you are
mother please tell us why you're not
sharing anything and please start to
talk about it that's all we're asking
you can take this as a clout thing I'm
doing this for clout what call it
whatever you want I'm a clout chaser I'm
a viewer I'm a I'm a Fame freak or
whatever you want to call it please talk
about the issue of the Palestinians and
the Gaza what is going there inshallah
that's all I have to say in I don't want
to carry on any further brothers and
sisters please once again I encourage
you guys to please do not send hate and
in so of that kind of stuff this not the
character of a Muslim we are sincerely
asking and just ask her a question
sister Nadia why are you not posting
about Gaza that's all I have to say
inshallah brother and sisters till next
time
alayum I don't want to be around the
bush have you heard of the saiman Norway
Masjid project your brothers and sisters
at Islam net are establishing a one-of
its kind Masjid da and Community Center
in the capital of Norway and they need
our urgent support now every person that
accepts Islam through this Center every
revert who learns about their Dean and
caus their family to the worship of
Allah subhana wa taala you will get the
rewards inshallah so here's what you
must do you must contribute to get your
rewards and share this project imagine
you meeting Allah subhana tala and
receiving the Glad Tidings of a palace
in Jenna because of this very Masid you
built with your Sak now you tell me what
Greater Joy can there be than getting a
house in Jenna with Gardens and rivers
of Honey walls built of bricks of gold
and silver morar of fragrant musk
Pebbles of Pearl and Sapphire and soil
of sappire front and whoever enters a
house in Jenna will be filled with joy
and will never feel miserable they will
live there forever and they will never
die they will get clothes that will
never wear out and their youth Will
Never Fade Away Subhan Allah these are
the descriptions of the houses in Jenna
that our beloved Prophet peace be upon
Him gave to his beloved companions would
you not want that for your afterlife
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the
video
h